hey guys what's up this is andrew for
transcendences.com so i'm here to make
an update on amc uh today and i will do
gamestop tomorrow we have uh quite a
blood bath guys on those two as well as
on other meme stocks so
let's go through the press action
through the news
let's try to understand what happened
here what are the dynamics of those
markets
and of course let's try to see what
might happen next so let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so i'm gonna start with
amc
um
all right
we can maybe first have a look at the
technicals then we're gonna very quickly
check the option market nothing very new
there but i have one thing that i want
to show you and let's try to understand
what is happening here so first
in terms of ta so as you can see still
the same situation i mean uh one two
three we are in a fourth wave and
this is what i'm actually struggling to
to do here i don't know if this
correction is still on or not okay let's
be honest i mean in my uh last video i
was making here a wxy correction in here
one two and then i was expecting three
four five so we should be in the third
wave right but in third waves we don't
have those gap downs you know that are
showing that bears totally take control
of the market even if it's only a few
days
so this is telling me that maybe this is
actually not what is happening
maybe we are more in a corrective mode
so to
answer this question let's first check
what are the reasons i think that we are
in a move up so
what
i can do here is to check uh if the
moves up are impulsive or corrected and
here i mean there is no other counting
that i can do here than one two three
four five all right here i have my
breakout that happened in august and one
two three four five i mean you can't
count three ways here so this is
impulsive and then here abc it looks
very much corrective
so
this tape discounting is still on the
table but like i just said this gap down
is not looking good at all so we're
gonna try to analyze where it's coming
from first what we can see is that the
volume was weak on that day 46 million
shares are traded which is not a lot for
such a strong move all right usually
when you have those strong moves if you
have a lot of i mean when you go
through a lot of price action you should
find a lot of traders in the way down or
up and it creates a strong volume that
shows that everybody agrees upon this
price which is not the case here
unfortunately it doesn't mean that we
can't go lower when we check to move
down here you know here the volume was
weak and then we went brutally lower so
it's just one thing to check but it's
not a guarantee of rebound at all
then what we can check is where are our
support levels so
this is quite easy to do which doesn't
mean once again that those supports
would hold but you just check the recent
load so the reason the most recent law
is here at 35.5 roughly so we have a
support here
the next one is okay you can put one at
33.5
but i would rather put the one this one
at 32.
it doesn't change much we have some
support here so all this area you have a
lot of recent lows which is good which
means that there are buyers that are
probably waiting there that couldn't get
in at this levels and that would very we
would be very happy to get in if we go
there maybe you are one of those buyers
so this is quite good that we have all
this uh recent laws quite close then
we can make a trendline so this trend
line is new i just added it today
uh so you it's it's like quite you know
whenever you see a trendline that is
having many reactions you know it's
good to use and here we have one two
three four and yesterday we got
almost a fixed reaction so we have here
a double support level all right a 35.5
so
it would be very good if it holds and on
the other way around it would not look
good at all if it breaks so it's very
important what is gonna happen here it
looks very much actually like jamie
jimmy is a bit in the same situation
with a massive triangle like you know
that really looks like a bull flag so of
course uh the ultimate breakout that you
want to see is here guys okay
so this would be to me a very good
signal to use for this fixed wave to be
really honored so let's try to analyze a
bit what
could have created this so when you
check the news there is nothing much to
find except that there are earnings that
are coming around the 1st of november
and
investors
seem to be afraid that the earnings
doesn't don't look good you know
so they're anticipating it and like i
was saying in my discord we have a
saying in trading that is by the rumor
and sell the news okay so this is
happening quite often whenever you have
some major announcements that you're not
going to happen investors like to
anticipate and be like oh it's going to
be good news so i'm going to buy right
now and whenever the announcement comes
even if it meets expectations
they don't have any more reason to buy
you know because it's passed so usually
just like we had on bitcoin etf you know
bitcoin went higher made new all-time
high and just got uh
sold off uh quite heavily yesterday
because there was no good news to cheer
about
and i'm pretty sure that bitcoin will go
to 100 000 within a few months uh but
we're just pulling back after the news
so here
maybe we're gonna have the opposite
reaction so investors are selling before
the news but actually
they are checked a bit and there are
good expectations about ticket sales in
october because people started to go
again in the cinema so this might
actually be a surprise
on the upside for the results to come so
let's see what i'm saying is that we
have a catalyzer coming
and we are right now soldier off without
volume on apparently new news so i think
that uh better days are about to come
but once again technically it would be
really really good if we can hold above
35.5 now let's analyze the scenario
because let's be honest guys this gap
down is nasty okay when you whenever you
have this kind of gap down i mean you
can check in the past but it's usually
not
good for the coming days
so i'm a bit scared actually that here
we break out on the downside so let's
analyze this case because we need to
know what will be the situation if this
happens
so like i said
we can have a fake out
and quickly come back okay so this is
possible okay this would be just a fake
out it happens so it would be very
important to check the volumes here if
the volume is weak on the breakout it's
fine i mean it's not fine but it's okay
if the volume is strong it's not good
so first thing then
this trend line would be broken so what
could be the other situation if we go
below 33.5
this would make a new low so this
couldn't be a one two anymore okay what
we are trying to have here is one two
three four five right five waves inside
uh our third wave
typical development but the second wave
cannot go below the start of the first
wave it's technically not acceptable
so then it would mean that this is
another correction and that we go lower
so if this counting is to be valid we
need to stay absolutely above 3.5 so
this gives us
another
level to watch in terms of our breakouts
below the stream line
okay if we
come back quickly like from here and
come back inside it will be okay
then if we stay here and we make new
loads then
probably what's what is happening is
that this of course is not anymore a one
two okay
this would be a massive corrective
pattern that we would need to label it
would maybe be a triangle a b c d e i
don't know probably a triangle by the
way
and we need to find the new base so
maybe the base would be here okay
because we have a 28 28
so if this breaks try to follow guys i'm
sorry there is a lot of drawings here
i'm just showing you the alternative
scenario so we can be prepared okay if
this is okay this would be all wrong
let's be very honest and it could be a
different
so a
b c
it's really not a perfect triangle okay
i would prefer it holds guys to be
honest i i struggle to find a good
counting i i prefer something like this
this is a triangle too and it makes more
sense but if it breaks we can always
have a triangle with a horizontal basis
that would still you know probably
create a bullish reaction
uh so what i'm saying is that basically
we have different countings it's of
course not clear here what is the right
one right now there's nothing else i can
say but what is clear is that we have
support at 35.5
we have support at 33.5 support at 32
support at 28 and a catalyzer coming
roughly in one week so i think we would
go lower here little bit once again
because of this gap down
but
probably one of the scenarios would be
good and from there we can expect this
once again uh come back here and
i'm really waiting you know anyway this
is coming guys this is coming because as
you can see this triangle even if i take
the most bearish case okay i could go to
24 if i take the most bearish case but
even in this situation
guys
we converge
so sorry
okay but depending when you put the
bases but roughly you know in gen 22
we're going to need to choose a
direction okay
it can actually take more time if the
basis is that low but if we get back to
the original basis
it would be november and if i go like i
don't know for example if i take this
one
i'm just trying to see when we're gonna
have a final answer because this is what
you guys want to know this is what i
want to know too
and
you know gen 22 here i'm i'm trying to
see whenever we have no other choice
than really making new laws or breaking
this trend line and as you can see this
trend line is going lower so in gen 22
it will be at 35
so
sooner or
drive l bulls back in amc another thing
i wanted to show you quickly guys you
know the spreadsheet i'm not gonna
explain again uh just i keep an eye on
the 145 strike and where which maturity
is coming from so as you can see we have
right now so the biggest amount of
shares comes from here
the amount is above 17 million so it's
growing guys which is good 17.3 million
so this just means that the move the
movement is not over at all and that
people still you know put money into
that strike because they believe in the
most so this is good and we can also see
that the gen 23 maturity is growing we
have almost 100 thousand calls right now
on it uh okay so we have three hundred
thousand calls on gen 22 but it's just
something i keep an eye on because as
long as
this would be full this would create
troubles for all market players on emc
like market makers hedge funds you know
this creates a lot of trouble so as long
as we have this
it means that uh something is up and
this is what i check for example on the
other stocks on the for example the
other memes like uh or prague they don't
have this let me show you quickly like
current for example they don't have at
all this kind of option distribution so
this is the difference to me between a
long-term squeeze and a short-term
squeeze you get here i check track so
the short is bigger 50
when you check where it's coming from
you can see that it's mostly coming
around the money you don't have okay you
can see here so we have 5 million shares
on the 2.5 strike the five strike is
growing little bit but it's only 100
amc is the 400 strike in terms of where
we are right now 145 is plus 300
compared to 36 so here it would be
around 9 10 you know we don't have that
even the eight strike is available
there's 7.5 there's nobody on this one
so this is just showing you once again
this is the reason why i personally
believe in the squeeze even if it takes
sometimes uh you know a different path
from what my tia is showing i still
believe in it and it's not easy let's be
honest uh this i mean i was expecting a
small pullback but definitely not a
strong bearish day like this so i will
keep guys updating you guys uh on this i
hope this is helpful for you i would
anyway keep doing that because i'm
involved in this trade and i do this to
know myself what i should do with my
position and of course there is no
question about getting out
we here for the squeeze
but it's interesting to know at what
level uh things are looking good or not
and if we should reload add more shares
options so this is the reason why i will
keep doing that so that's it for today i
hope you guys enjoyed this video and if
you did please don't forget to click on
the sub like and bell button so you're
going to be the first to know when i
upload anything new and stay close to
shore see you guys